les Chéries alors voilà donc ça c'était
incroyable aussi on va revenir
maintenant on va commencer à rentrer
dans les sujets les sujets que vous
attendez hein bien entendu euh de Yach
euh d'abord le dossier bravem au bout de
20 minutes il dévoileent ce qui pour eux
et l'élément phare de leur enquête la
fameuse séquence sur la bravem le 31
mars dernier nous recevions sur ce
plateau plusieurs policiers dont un de
la bravem on regarde ce qu'ils ont dit
et je vous explique ce qui s'est passé
avec Lionel Stan qui a toutes les infos
c'est parti ah et ben nous a dit bah
finalement on va vous présenter comme
quatre policiers de la bravem au moment
de raccrocher et là en fait on dit St
stop on arrête tout ça c'est hors de
question j'ai eu nos juristes et avocats
ils sont unanimes ils m'interdisent
l'intervention en plateau sur cette
présentation je pouvais pas être
beaucoup plus clair la condition
impérative ça c'est sûr et certain c'est
que à aucun moment il ne puisse être
identifié et pourtant dans le rapport de
l'IGPN nous sommes tombés sur ce mail
signé de dionel Stan il écrite au
commissaire chargé de l'enquête
administrative vous trouverez en pièce
jointe les quatre prénoms et numéros de
le téléphone des policiers en plateau
les trois rectos de leur carte de police
franchement ça ça m'a choqué et oui ah
oui alors euh oui alors déjà juste un
point apparemment à l'IGPN c'est très
très facile d'y aller avec une caméra et
de ressortir tous les mails je me suis
entretenu j'ai appelé quelqu'un cet
après-midi au au ministère de
l'intérieur parce que j'étais choqué de
cette séquence ça reste quand même des
mails encore une fois envoyé à l'gpn il
laisse filmer le nom les cartes
professionnelles de policiers tout
naturellement alors là-dessus qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé je suis très énervé
contre cette journaliste Virginie
Villard puisquelle m'a tout simplement
appelé en me disant Lionel vous avez
envoyé un mail avec les identités des
policiers à l'IGPN je lui dit non
l'émission a été diffusé le en direct
bien sûr le 31 c'était 31 mars j'ai reçu
une réquisition judiciaire on l'a là en
bontire donc c'est la justice qui
m'oblige de donner l'identité de ces
quatre policiers
pourtant c'est vrai que le préfet de
police sur le plateau s'est engagé à ne
pas nous les demander j'ai appelé ce
capitaine de la police judiciaire je lui
dis écoutez le préfet de police s'est
engagé ce capitaine m'a répondu tout
simplement c'est la justice qui vous
demande les noms vous êtes dans
l'obligation de les donner Diana a
prévenu l'ensemble des policiers
immédiatement qu'on avait eu cette
réquisition judiciaire j'ai été vous
l'avez vu le doc hier piégé Virginie
Villard dit je n'ai pas dit voil là je
j'enregistre cette conversation Lionel
Stan ne le sait pas à son insue mais
elle m'a appelé je lui dis les choses je
lui ai envoyé cette réquisition
judiciaire pourquoi elle m'a pas dit
j'ai besoin d'un sonore de votre part
tout simplement pour me dire que 7 jours
après vous avez reçu cette réquisition
judiciaire j'ai eu cette conversation
avec Tristan valex ce matin il me
lui-même m'a dit je le dis qu'il a été
étonné de ce passage parce queil savait
que j'avais envoyé la réquisition
judiciaire mais il me dit c'est le
juridique qui a lu le qui a vu le
documentaire et apparemment on a
l'habitude de préciser que cette
conversation est enregistrée à son insu
je comprends apprécie beaucoup Cédric
avec qui je je voilà avec qui je voilà
on interagit tous les deux j'aime
beaucoup ce garçon et voilà moi ce que
je voulais c'est pas pas lui poser de
problème parce que j'aime beaucoup
vraiment garçon et il était aussi
d'ailleurs il il a parlé de complément
d'enquête aujourd'hui il était avec
Bruno Attal regardez et il a dit il
raconte que les équipes de Tristan Alex
ont supprimé supprimé tout ce qu'il
avait dit de bien sur moi Cédric euh
regardez c'est ce qu'il a dit à Bruno
regardez il m'ont aussi contacté j'ai vu
avec eux donc ils m'ont dit tu as du mal
à dire sur Cyril Hanouna non bon ben on
passe à quelqu'un d'autre alors moi je
voulais dire juste que cyil Amouna voilà
je me suis pris la tête plusieurs fois
avec lui mais il a toujours été réglo et
surtout c'est le seul qui qui t'invite
même quand tu es pas d'accord avec lui
voilà c'est ce que je leur ai dit donc
du coup je pense que j'ai basé
l'émission j'ai rien reproché à cyriluna
donc Cyril c'est le premier qui était
victime qui pensait qu'il y avait quatre
mecs de la brave par contre moi sur sur
complément d'enquête je l'ai précisé que
bah cyril est au courant de rien ça je
le dis ça bien sûr ça ça va pas passer
dans le complément d'enquête
merci céric et merci c'est vrai que
Bruno Atal je suis pas d'accord avec toi
sur plein de trucs on l'invite ici comme
plein d'autres gens voilà et c'est c'est
insupportable C gens qui disent on doit
inviter un tel pas un tel pas un tel on
n pas d'accord sur des trucs on
s'engueulit plein de fois il vient il
vient pas et avec plein d'autres gens
pareil des gens des gens de gauche des
gens de droite on est comme ça il a
aussi tenu a préciser qu'on lui avait
jamais dit quoi dire et qu'au contraire
il avait pu dire tout ce qu'il voulait
CDC regardez ça important aussi ce que
dit Cédric Val j'ai C ou si fois tes PMP
on m'a jamais dit tu dois dire ça ça ça
toi est-ce que c'était tu l'as fait une
foisune fois ouais ils t'ont demandé ils
t'ont demandé de scénariser ils t'ont
demandé de de de un discours ou pas non
non absolument pas ça par contre ça çail
faut reconnaître à cyil Anouna et même
du coup à ses équipes c'est que tu vas
là-bas et tu es libre et on l'a vu parce
que c'est dommage que après le replay é
enlevé mais on l'a vu moi j'ai pas on a
eu quasiment 20 minutes de temps de
parole c'est énorme voilà et et et donc
nous on a des on a des mecs qui
témoignent à visage découvert
contrairement à complément d'enquête
c'est pas des mecs on peut on nous dit
tout ce qu'il faut dire et qu'on voit
pas et on a changé la voix les mecs on
les voit que ce soit Bruno hatal ou
Cédric on les voit à visage découvert
voilà donc je vous dis n'importe quoi
Cyril un point important sur cette
séquence l'extrait qui a été diffusé
hier quand vous présentez ces policiers
comme quatre membres de la bravem
immédiatement Cédric reprend la
présentation et vous dit pourquoi ça a
été coupé hier comend on va vous le
montrer on l'a ça on l'a normalement
c'est ça on ce qu' n ça on l'a pas c'est
les seules gages sontous à nous aussi on
a des génies hein non non c'est on va
vous le mettre
lundi on va vous mettre sur les réseaux
on va le mettre sur CDC reprend
immédiatement nous ne sommes pas tous de
la bravem il le dit et nous changeons ce
qu'on appelle le SAÉ ce que vous lisez
tous à l'antenne tout de suite en disant
que ce sont des forces spécial qui ont
l'habitude d'intervenir sur le terrain
voilà voilà qure policiers ça c'était
unité spécial sortte du silence et voilà
et on reprend immédiatement Cédric
reprend immédiatement la présentation et
l'extraè n'est pas laissé je sais pas
pourquoi 23h35 qui donne la parole à un
garçon Michel Zazoun un pharmacien qui a
fait un peu de radio qui prétend que je
serais homophobe et que ma mère l'aurait
menacé par téléphone al c'est vrai que
ma mère l'a menacé par téléphone ça je
vous dis c'est vrai elle a préend 6 fois
je comprends tout à fait voilà c'est ma
mère je la défendrai toujours et je vais
vous dire en fait il faut que je vous
explique le contexte parce que ce garçon
il sort pas de nulle part donc je vais
vous raconter l'histoire qu' raconte pas
en complément d'enquête donc je vais
vous la raconter regardez l'interview de
Zazou un jour un de ses collègues lui
rapporte une phrase que Cyril Hanouna
aurait prononcé il a dit tout fort je
vais pasigner Zazoun zazun c'est un péd
les péd ça finit toujours par t'enculer
là je me dis j'ai pas envie de bosser
pour cette personne là en fait dimanche
je commence à recevoir deux appels de
coup de fil anonyme je fais pas gaffe et
et soudainement au bout de je saais pas
vous dire 10 12 appels quasi quasi
d'affilé et il y a un blanc j'entends tu
as pas honte de ce que tu as fait à
siréanouna BIM un policier l'appelle on
sait qui vous a harcelé au téléphone
elle me dit c'est Madame Hanouna c'est
pas une fan c'est sa mère qui se croit
toute puissante omnipotente à l'insté de
son fils et qui se permet de faire ça
sans problème alors je vous explique
l'histoire ce qu'il disent pas dans ce
documentaire c'est que ma maman était
très très amie avec sa mère et que sa
mère donc c'est elles sont très très
amies d'enfance elles étaient en Tunisie
ensemble euh je vous dis sa mère voilà
donc ils se connaissent très très bien
et sa mère ma mère en lui disant mon
fils est pharmacien et ton fils il peut
pas c'est un jour un truc il a un truc à
la radio et donc j'ai dit à ma mère un
moment je cherchais un médecin et donc
je l'ai mis à la radio avec Jean-Michel
mer etura Michel Zazoun mais moi
j'allais jamais à la radio c'est moi qui
produisais j'y allais jamais je vous dis
la vérité voilà je j'is pas du tout et
c'est vrai que sa mère saoulait ma mère
pour qu'il fasse de l'antenne donc je
l'ai mis à la radio et moi je le
connaissais un petit peu je vous dis on
partait en vacances ensemble et je vous
dis même petite anecdote quand on était
petit il a un an de on est je crois
qu'on a le même âge euh voilà voilà
comme j'étais souvent d'ca voilà je
faisais des petits coups je fait manger
une boule puante voilà c'est non mais
c'est vrai voilà et donc sa mère elle
m'a sa mère elle m'a
esquinté voilà il avait on avait 10 ans
tous les deux voilà moi j'étais un petit
peu le chef de la de la bande et donc
voilà je lui dit tiens venez on mange
des boules puantes il a mangé une boule
puante il disait ça fait des bulles
voilà je m'en rappelle très bien voilà
c'est les amis de ma mère c'est pour ça
qu'il est filmé de loin là encore mais
je vous dis c'est vrai et donc ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que ce gars pourquoi
ma mère l'a mal pris ma mère en fait
elle s'est sentie trahie elle se dit
c'est moi qui a dit à mon fils de le
mettre à la radio ou il le met à la
radio et derrière il fait des post sur
les réseaux contre mon fils donc elle
est partie en Vrie et là je vous le dis
elle lui a dit ouais tu sais pas qui on
est la famille Hanouna tu as s notre nom
on va te défoncer et cetera elle a été
jugée 444 € BIM voilà merci elle a fait
une lettre d'excuse et voilà aujourd'hui
elle est tout à fait calme voilà vous
pouvez continuer à m'insulter elle ne
vous appellera pas non non voilà mais
c'est important de savoir le contexte
parce que c'est pas un mec qui sort de N
par
et c'est un gars et et quand il dit et
le propos homophobe il dit c'est un gars
d'un gars qui lui a dit que c'était un
gars qui lui a dit voilà donc on sait
même pas oui j'ai une anecdote sur ce
passage parce que j'étais là quand on a
su que c'était votre maman et votre
maman vous a appelé dit mais comment ils
savent que c'est moi tu simplement
répondu c'est ton numéro maman c'est
[Applaudissements]
c'est histoire
vraie qui essaie toujours de couvrir un
ver je lui dis mais qu'est-ce qu'elle me
dit non rien de
fou dit mais elle l'insulte
non pas de ouf je vous dis et ma mère il
sait pas que c'est ma mère je vous donne
un autre truc ma mère un jour il y a un
mec aussi Qui a parlé mal de moi euh un
comédien je vous le dis il sait pas que
c'est ma mère elle l'a vu dans la rue
elle lui a mis un mollard voilà donc
voilà